[Musique]
vous
la chine a sauté vers la caraïbe à son
pays capra riabi flora pour les initier
une plante d'environ un mètre à un mètre
cinquante sur laquelle pousse de petites
fleurs blanches à cinq pétales et des
feuilles vertes de moins de 10 cm on va
là la base leurs extrémités pointues
leur donne l'air d'avoir des dents
aiguisées
mais même avec du caractère le thé pays
et d'une douceur et d'une efficacité
sans égal
présent partout dans la caraïbes et en
amérique centrale on le trouve aussi
désormais au cap-vert et à l'île maurice
chez nous c'est une plante médicinale
bien ancrée dans la culture
[Musique]
dans toute la région on ya recours pour
aider à la digestion et soulager des gaz
les coliques et la constipation
elle est aussi consommer lorsqu'on
attrape froid pour lutter contre le
rhume les encombrements bréchique et la
fièvre
enfin certains affectionne dans le
traitement de l'hypertension
il contient des polyphénols notamment
des flavonoïdes et des tanins qui sont
de puissants antioxydants
une qualité sur laquelle travaille le
parme le pôle agro ressources et de
recherche de martinique dans le cadre de
son projet pemble
les recherches dopants ont permis de
mettre en évidence une activité anti
diabétique de certains extraits de thé
pays
chan s'est extrait on a remarqué en fait
une diminution du public du glucose
hépatique et une stimulation de la
sécrétion d'insuline
quand il était testée sur des cellules
de rats ce qui est intéressant dans ses
résultats c'est qu'on peut envisager
donc l'utilisation d'extraits de ces
pays dans la lutte contre le diabète
l'idée aujourd'hui pour le peuple c'est
de poursuivre ses travaux de recherche
justement en approfondissant les
premiers résultats obtenus et de pouvoir
attester ses extraits sur l'homme
ce qu'on espère avec
cette étude c'est de développer un
complément alimentaire à visée
antidiabétique voilà pour les vins sont
inquiets
en attendant de confirmer ces précieuses
propriété comme nombre de nos plantes
médicinales le thé pays est aussi
utilisé pour ses qualités aromatiques en
cuisine pour le goût ou pour les
douleurs
capra riabi flora est un vrai trésor de
nos jardins mais attention quel que soit
le mal que vous voulez traiter il faut
toujours être prudent
si les plantes peuvent soigner mieux
vaut demander conseil à votre médecin
[Musique]